Chỉ Nam dễ sắp bị phà ban đầu trong qua đủ thịt giao đầu
Thơi thành trong ngày mắt sẽ giúp qua em làm được câu này
Chỉ em biết hổi phà ban đầu trong xong sau đúng biểu vào đó là thơ giúp tay bằng không
Qua ạ
Thơ giúp tay bằng không
Ngày, gần đang là một vị trí nào trạng thấy nạn
Thì với câu tiền xin của như vậy
Phà ban đầu sẽ được xa định bảo kinh net đầu tiên vụ lụ tình xin
Vì em biết hổi quốc để là những câu này là câu tình xe tế bằng không
Chỉ có net bảo kêu tiền xúc phà lỡ đau thì nó sẽ nằm lại
Thì phà đầu sẽ nằm lại
Chỉ mấy người đau không Schmidt
Chỉ em biết hổi thợ gi полит
Chỉ mấy người đau không
Chỉ mấy người ạ
Thấy người một bảo kêu đau
Chỉ mấy người đau không
Bình dường, bình dường thì nhìn là phà lòng không đối.
Còn quà.
Anh, là có một thời gian nữa là phà không tìm.
Đây, mình này.
Phà không tìm đi nhé.
Thôi điểm tây bằng không nào mà bị chí thì có ạ.
Tếm mặt ở mà.
Bình gặp biệt của lòng.
Cà mà bị nâm, thì phà bà đầu, mình không tìm.
Anh, cái cái bị chí cơ bà.
Bây giờ có thể nhé là phà bây, mình chỉ cũng tạo hơn.
Bây giờ mình sẽ làm cô hòa.
Cói, mình chỉ cũng tạo hô.
Quang, ở phà, viên nhé.
Bây giờ là sẽ gây.
Ờ, có 2 cái góc phà nào là không một viên thôi.
Còn phà nào là bị chí cơ bằng.
Bây giờ là phà nào, bị chí cơ bằng, thì đấy.
Bây giờ có kìo này.
Nó nằm bị chí cơ bằng của anh đi xuống luôn.
Tất bằng đi xuống đi phà nào mà, nhé.
Cái thật hiểm tây bằng không.
Tếc bằng không của anh của xuống dạ.
Bây giờ là phà nào, bằng xuống bị chí này.
xuống phà, có thể đi ở chỗ không?
Bây giờ, xuống dạ.
xuống dạ, có thể có chỗ anh đi theo chỗ không?
Bây giờ là bình dương rồi.
Thơ điểm tây bằng không, bình dương luôn.
Bây giờ là phà nào đầu mấy em.
Mằng không của này xuống như thế này.
Bây giờ, nhưng mà có 2 thì mình là món hạnh.
Bây giờ là dạ, có 2 thì em.
Em muốn biết phà nào đầu ở đâu để bếm chỗ nào chỗ qua.
Bây giờ là chỗ chủ quy mà, nó chủ chủ quyết đầu.
Đúng không?
Bây giờ là phà nào đầu của quyền.
Em mong rất là cái này, nó phải là phà nào đầu của quyền.
Bây giờ, nhưng phà nào đầu, người ta nói, thì nó phải là phà nào đầu của quyền.
Bây giờ là phà nào đầu, nó sẽ phà nào đầu của quyền.
Bây giờ, thế này là, ở đây là phà này.
Cũng hiểu nhạc.
Tếm gì nữa, thầy nhá, nó nó mà đầu.
Bây giờ, 2 mươi này, 2 mươi, 1 mươi, 1 kỳ.
Cũng là cái gì về mạc.
Tìm mươi của nó mà bà đầu, nó có cái gì mươi.
Chỉ nó là cái gì về mắc thái 2 và đăng soống dạ.
Bộ đi đâu?
Bây mắc trên 2 và có xuống dạm.
Bắc tơ, nó mà đo em.
Bây mắc trên 2 lên, không?
Bây mắc trên 2 đây.
Cũng sạm là soống dạm.
Đúng không?
Bây dạm.
Soống dạm.
Cũng hiểu không?
Tăng chuyện với đi từ âm với mắc.
Bây mắc.
Cũng sạm, đi từ với mắc.
Bây mắn.
Bây mắn ở đây, mình mới só lên chủ ích.
Hãy nó chứ nhạc, phà mà đầu.
Bây mắn trên 2 thì có ai sống với độ của này.
Bây mắn mấy độ.
Vìa, vìa phá bà đầu, nó chứ anh góc mày này
Mình yêu tâm biến sấu
Vìa, anh nó phải đánh như bà